Verde Johnson joining us here once again
on the show how you demand meet a I'm
doing great rich how about you I'm
hanging in there I'm hanging in there
better for having you here Cubs are
different team now Ernie huh yeah yeah
without question I was you know the day
before the all-star break we had two
Cubs and Pirates play in and Jon Lester
gave up 10 runs in the first inning and
that Cubs were struggling and
everybody's saying hey are they even
going to make it and and then when you
go 11 and 2 out of the break and you
have your longest winning streak and the
Brewers have their longest losing streak
at the same time it's amazing how that
how that gap shrinks and now that Cubs
got the game and a half leak as we go
into this series and yeah so good stuff
and looking forward to it and going home
to to Milwaukee where I was born and so
it's always always good to revisit the
mean streets of Wauwatosa go back to
Michigan yeah I don't know they made a
Scorsese movie out of that or not
not it was in her words the power fell
apart but it'll be interesting you'll be
in Milwaukee on the day that Bud Selig
goes into Cooperstown as well that'll be
interesting yeah
yes indeed but it's you know it's
Milwaukee the great Milwaukee the great
baseball City and then when you have
them playing the Cubs and it's a short
ride for all the Cubs fans so it's it's
going to be a great atmosphere and and
looking forward to being up there okay
and yeah and schwarber had a couple of
dingers and they suddenly have a
three-game lead in the lost column over
Milwaukee just one and a half right
there but that but the Dodgers just
appear invincible right now Ernie I
don't know how anybody gets past them
but maybe the Cubs could do that if they
faced one another Washington sitting
there as well yeah I mean but I mean
right now would be you know it would be
Chicago Washington who would play in the
in the NLDS and the Dodgers and you know
you wonder about Clayton Kershaw
obviously with the back problem and
we'll see if you know how he comes back
and if he is able to come back and that
kind of thing but yeah there when you're
sitting 71 and 31 MedX that's pretty
darn impressive when you're 40 games
over 500 so
these games are always fun and you're
getting into that time now where where
the series these head-to-head series
mean so much and so you know it's a huge
series I think from the walkie to try to
reestablish themselves and see if they
can stay close they can't they can't
lose a series Ernie Johnson joining here
talking a little bit uh the lead
play-by-play announcer for MLB on TBS
and Turner Sports joining me here on the
show I'm feeling that this it's
different with the NBA now and months
like June and July
Ernie worse things change once the the
playoffs are over and August now might
have some little bit of conversation
with the Kyrie drama you feeling the
same thing yeah I mean the season that
Ritz and it used to be that you know the
NBA to the 20 at least and you and
you're talking about the league but not
that's not the way it is anymore and
before you know it they'll be they'll be
in camps and getting ready for a season
that's going to start a little earlier
this year in in October so no it's been
a year-long deal and then and then yeah
you have these stories that that come up
and then the Kyrie thing is a little
mystifying to me and you know because
you see a team that's got all those
pieces but it almost almost says to me
that you know from from what he saw in
the finals that this that Cleveland team
wasn't going to beat open state in the
finals if it comes down to that again
and and it's it's just interesting to me
though you know the mindset of of
players and wanting to be the guy as
Kyrie you know wants to be and so just
the it's just the the mindset is kind of
shifting to me and and it's and it's and
it's a little distressing isn't that
incredible but in the era of the super
team that one team that D team that has
the best chance of des throwning the
super team of all super teams right now
in the Warriors could be torn asunder
because somebody doesn't want to be part
of a super team wants to start his own
team
it's really a that to me is one of the
more fascinating wrinkles of the Kyrie
split if you will sure yeah I mean it's
a you know no I in team kind of a thing
but it implies retirees like I don't
want to be in the guy shadow even though
you've got a you've got a team there
that is you know far and away the best
in the Eastern Conference and now when
you look at Kyrie wanting to be moved
and all the talk about LeBron leaving
after the next season that you could be
back to the Cleveland of old you know
unless you unless you do make a deal on
the Kyrie thing and pick up some really
good pieces that that you know that make
for a good future but that's yeah it's
it's been it's been an intriguing thing
I mean you when you go back to the Kevin
Durant situation and you thought about
the thought about a team that was that
close to winning the Western Conference
and then he wants out and then and now
here's here's Kyrie sayin
look I know I'm the big part of this
thing and I want to want to be the guy
and and so you're looking at a team
Cleveland that could be just a shell of
themselves if these things if these
dominoes fall like like people are
saying they were well I just know how it
is on on my set on game day morning
where you know I've got my Hall of
Famers to my left and you know their
texts blow up their phones blow up
there's all sorts of rumors and you know
they're talking about what's going on in
locker rooms and stories don't get
reported because there's really you know
nothing to actually report it's just
rumors in conjecture and then a story
happens and suddenly the rumors and
conjecture have all been fact all along
have you heard anything on you know just
sitting on the set there about Kyrie and
LeBrons relationship that this makes
sense or were you just as surprised no I
was surprised I mean certainly like when
you go back to the Durant Westbrook
dynamic there you knew that you know
something was up and that you know maybe
things were not great between those two
superstars but no this is to me did hit
me kind of out of left field
I'll be honest with you I mean I just
thought that this was this was a team
that
like look we're set at this position
we're set at this position these guys
play well together and they want a
championship together and yes so let you
know it surprised me without question
Ernie Johnson joining me here for a
couple more minutes on the Rich Eisen
show and now you're and you're going to
North Carolina next week to be part of
the PGA Championship coverage who do you
think you know you'll see Jordan
Spieth's show up there that was an
incredible moment we saw him at the at
the at the Open Championship I almost
said British Open where of course I mean
that was unbelievable are you I know I
almost spat in the face of tradition
right there what'd you think of what'd
you think of space performance well I
love that I love that final round as
just a fan you want to see things
tighten up you know I don't want to see
somebody run away with it the final
round I wanted to see know with him and
Kuchar side-by-side and then to see the
lead escape him and and and that's when
I started thinking what's going on in
Jordan speeds mind right now is he going
back to Augusta now is he going back to
saying and again I'm not him and so I
don't know what players think what is he
thinking and I would have to answer
these questions again about a
final-round lead and all of a sudden you
know after that adventure at the 13th
they hit a tee shot as close as he did
on the 14th birdie right there having
lost the lead momentarily and then you
know it was a tremendous run and I think
it showed a lot of mental fortitude on
his part and along with the shot making
and and so no I was great it was great
drama
it was great theater and as you know
when you go to Quail Hollow you're
hoping for the same kind of thing that
playing out in four days up there in
North Carolina so I just kind of hit me
I feel sort of silly Ernie just a go
full circle here that you're going again
calling Cubs brewers from Milwaukee back
where you were born that's because your
dad your dad was a Milwaukee brave
through and through right yeah oh but I
questioned it
Boston Braves Milwaukee Braves World
Series in 1957 and yeah I mean that's
where I that's where I grew up and and
it is special because I can you know I
can drive through my old neighborhood as
I've done when we go to Whistling
Straits the last time you were there for
the PGA Championship I was driving back
to the airport and said well let's go
back down or 68th Street see what's
going on and I took a picture of the old
house and then the folks who lived there
came out and because I'd been there
before and actually one year had taken
my son with me and I said here's the
house where I grew up and I knocked on
the door and the people came there I
said I explained what was happening and
they said well c'mon in look around
maybe so it was it was amazing the house
looked the same the yard looked the same
and for them to just say come on in and
look around and then when I went back to
take a picture the next time I was there
the folks came out again and say hey how
you doing it's just it's just horrendous
well I don't want to take I was going to
ask you one more question but I don't
want to take you from the phone call
Ernie that's coming over lately yes it's
being screened okay very good
because we had Reggie Jackson on the
horn a couple weeks ago and and he put
he stopped the interview to say hold on
a second it's Hal Steinbrenner on the
phone and he took that call to say I'll
call you right back
and fully admit it fully admit he would
not have done that with George if George
was the one who was calling in no this
is this was this is not nearly the
gravitas of that phone call yeah this is
this can be this can be returned like so
do you do you have a good story the
first time you ever met Hank Aaron Ernie
uh I don't know if I remember the first
time I met him but I remember you know
hanging out with my dad when he was a
broadcaster and you know going down to
the ballpark you know five six hours
early and always standing around the
batting cage and watching BP and and
Hank Aaron's asked me how my little
league team is doing no later later his
sons went to the same high school that I
did and so I've known Henry for forever
and ever he's just just a prince of a
man and
and but those were special times then I
mean the first time you ever hang out in
the big league club house and you have
no idea what you're going to see and you
know you see a backup that you're
walking by with just a towel and a
cigarette and you're saying well this is
not what I expected
yeah it was a it was quite an
introduction to the grand old game
that's for sure yeah and we're showing a
picture of Hank after he broke the
record
and there's craig sager at home play in
d we're showing that picture right now
Ernie oh that's it was so you know that
was saved too
you know CEG's was such a go-getter and
wanted to be wherever the big story was
happening and so for him to be with you
know within the white trenchcoat and the
and the same haircut he always supported
even back then into into all of his time
at Turner and he just was a guy who's
you're not going to tell him no you know
I'm oh he just hit the home run I'm
going to be on the field which would
never happened today you don't think but
if there's one guy who could make his
way to the field for historic moment
these days it would have been pretty
good I bet Ernie always loved Chapman do
you enjoy the the ballpark this weekend
and then obviously the golf course the
following week for the final major of
the year yeah it's always great talking
to your ritual things as well in your
world and we'll talk against it all good
Ernie
football's right around the corner love
doing this show I've got I'm growing
facial hair because I can't grow it on
top so everything's good 14 and 2 for
the Patriots is that ready 14 and 2 ok
I'll write you down Ernie
so vote them down or no on the Pope like
14 and 2 I'm with you not not 19 and Oh
Ernie I'm with out I don't just too hard
it's just it's just too hard to not slip
up with 1 or 2 weeks not great what
Deena - all right thank to the bank
we'll chat soon that journey Johnson so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country
and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy